welcome to the 50 brain cell challenge
so the way the 50 brain cell challenge
works is every one ingredient is minus
one brain cell and you have 50 brain
cells at the beginning of the day in
your job is to Ed up with the most brain
cells at the end of the day so if you
ate this you would have failed to 50
brain s hi Joshua I don't know what your
credentials are to create and sell a
diet and challenge because your bio
doesn't really list any legitimate
credentials but I am happy to report
that there is no evidence that you lose
a brain cell for every ingredient that
you consume and even if you did fail The
Challenge and lose all 50 of those brain
cells a day you would still have 85
billion 999 million 999,000 and
950 more your brain is going to be okay
if you occasionally eat something out of
a box now obviously we know that a
Mediterranean style diet rich in fruits
and vegetables whole grains nuts legumes
and fish and low in Ultra processed
foods is associated with improved brain
health so I'm not saying that having
hungry men dinners every single day is a
brain healthy way to eat but it is a
super oversimplified over
sensationalized and over fear mongered
way to teach nutrition